mais d'abord le lancement officiel de la
campagne des candidats d'ensemble la
coalition de la majorité
présidentielle hugo lemonnier avec
mathias arese comme un air de rentrée
des classes pour les candidats de la
majorité présidentielle
une journée de formation avant tout
dédié aux aspirants députés investi pour
la première fois législatives soit
environ la moitié des candidats c'est à
nous aussi de leur apporter un peu de
notre expérience et de notre expérience
de la campagne passée de 2017
pourquoi qui commettent des erreurs pour
pour les orienter vers ce qu'il faut
faire et ne pas faire au programme la
stratégie électorale une séance de
photos pour les affiches de campagne et
enfin le discours de clôture du
président de la république venu
mobiliser les troupes pour cette
première élection sous l'étiquette
ensemble les grandes manoeuvres à
l'extrême gauche et à l'extrême droite
ne font que commencer
moi j'espère qu'il restera une droite
républicaine une gauche républicaine
dans ce pays
mais s'il nous est donné d'affronter
uniquement l'extrême gauche et l'extrême
droite il faudra qu'on soit solide c'est
pour ça que c'est symbolique parce qu'il
ya cinq ans voilà emmanuel macron
n'était pas venu à la première réunion
des candidats là il vient parce que
parce qu'on a besoin
non seulement de tenir les engagements
qu'il a pris
mais certainement d'être au rendez vous
de l'histoire cible de la majorité dans
cette entrée en campagne la gauche et
son nouveau chef de file jean luc
mélenchon on voit beaucoup la france ont
misé cette alliance qui s'appelle nul
c'est que moi j'appelle du plq parce
qu'en fait c'est un marché de dupes
c'est à dire c'est une alliance purement
électoralistes ya maintenant un bloc à
gauche avec des candidats mélenchonistes
puisqu'ils font campagne pour que jean
luc mélenchon soit premier ministre
alors même qu'il n'est pas candidat et
puis à une majorité présentielle est
engagée dans cette élection non pas dans
une volonté de confrontation mais dans
une volonté d'action une nouvelle liste
de 50 à 65 candidat investi par la
majorité est toujours en attente des non
validées par emmanuel macron en personne
et on décortique cette liste de
candidats aux législatives qui
pourraient pour de nombreux d'entre eux
devenir député en tout cas on va en
débattre avec mes invités béatrice
giblin bonsoir soir êtes géographe
géopolitologue et directrice de la revue
hérodote bonsoir il s'agit rebond
bienvenu vous est la fondatrice du
cercle de réflexion france audacieuse
j'accueille également jean daniel lévy
directeur délégué chez harris
interactive en france bonsoir jean
daniel bienvenue laetitia cru pas
bienvenu senlis politique donc je
rappelle quelques chiffres 50 9 509
pardon circonscriptions qui sont déjà
pourvus à 274 député sortant reconduit
sur les 346 actuel est de 135 nouveaux
candidats béatrice giblin est ce que
vous diriez que emmanuel macron à
attirer un peu la leçon de des
précédentes élections législatives
notamment sur la part de la société
civile
incontestablement on était parti d'abord
parce qu'il avait pas tellement d' ils
sont déjà élus à se mettre joyeusement
exactement il fallait quand même bien
des trouver les 577 puis c'était l'idée
que au fond d'elle et sortir des
professionnels de la politique et la
société civile allaient pouvoir comme ça
à travailler enfin on réformer la france
et ont réformé aussi au niveau de
l'assemblée nationale bon on a compris
que c'était pas si facile que ça de
s'improviser députés que quand on
n'avait jamais exercé aucun mandat
certains avaient été conseiller
municipal et avait quand même une petite
expérience mais pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux s'étaient pas le cas du tout
bon il a eu une très très large majorité
il a eu une majorité où il avait dit
d'entrée de jeu mois les frondeurs c'est
non un don que ce soit bien clair vous
appartenait à ma majorité et vous allez
de travailler dans le sens où je décide
que vous allez travailler il avait vu le
mal que ça avait proposé ils ont
contribué à la mort du ps
incontestablement bon donc déjà il ya eu
là quelque chose de très de très nettes
et puis bah on a appris au cours des
cinq ans donc un grand nombre d'entre
eux n'ont pas démérité puis vous savez
être député sais pas si désagréable que
ça
donc quand on fait un discours assez
négatif mais quand il faut lâcher le
post c'est déjà devenu un peu plus
difficile donc il y en a beaucoup qui
sont très heureux de didier retourner
alarcon et on en a quelques-uns qui
avait décidé d'arrêter souvent parce que
ils ont aussi des professions qui fait
que s'ils s'éloignent trop longtemps ça
va pas forcément être si facile que ça à
dire tourner donc tout le monde ne peut
pas si facilement que ça à reprendre son
sang son poste donc on peut parfaitement
le comprendre il y en a quelques-uns qui
ont peut-être pas montré une loyauté
aussi
exigeante que le président la souhaitons
on voit bien comment la loyauté la à
jouer sur un certain nombre de gens qui
se sont retrouvés investi
incontestablement et puis à quelques
paris sur certains qui vont rester l'air
mais il faudra qu'il s'engage quand ils
vont s'inscrire à la préfecture pour
dire d'entrée de jeu avec qui ils vont
aller travailler par la suite et il
aurait intérêt et ils ont bien compris à
dire avec qui ils vont aller c'est pas
avec 16e au fond ne faut pas oublier
c'est aussi une synthèse entre les
différents partis d'ensemble c'est on
parle d'une coalition oui on parle d'une
coalition puisque comme tout va très
vite aujourd'hui c'est même pas une
question de jours c'est une question
d'heure 1-1 quasiment on voit bien qu'on
est passé de l'idée du parti unique qui
a été mis de côté à la confédération
avec trois partis fondateurs avec des
attributions des investitures qui ont
été données en fonction du poids
politique aussi évidemment avec le modem
qu'à une centaine
d'investiture et puis horizon qui en a
58 de mémoire et qui intervient dans le
paysage politique comme un nouveau venu
aussi donc c'est ce rapport de force est
en train de s'établir je crois que
également c'est le reflet aujourd'hui
d'une d'un quinquennat qui s'annonce
quand même extrêmement difficile parce
que bon c'est une chose d'avoir été
réélu mais dans une configuration
géopolitique économique vous allez en
parler ensemble la partie après
particulièrement délicate et tous les
voyants sont aussi au rouge dans le sens
d'une projection sur les années qui
viennent donc
avoir des gens issus de la société
civile moi je reste persuadé que ça peut
être un fort à tous si et seulement si
ces personnalités issues de la société
civile arrive très vite à comprendre
aussi les règles du jeu politique c'est
à dire que je crois que non seulement
cette loyauté dans ton partenaire
notamment notamment le la loyauté
notamment le fait qu' il faut être
compétent mais il ya aussi des rapports
de force qui est qui existe en politique
savoir aussi prendre la parole d'une
façon qui soit équilibrée juste c'est à
dire que on voit bien qu'il y a du
métier chez ceux qui ont qui exerce la
chose publique en cela les mandats
électifs sont extrêmement formateur y
compris pour la société civile parce que
vous devez vous exprimer aussi à la fois
sur des projets mais face à des
majorités qui sont parfois à défendre
des idées qui qui qui nécessite de
trouver un terrain d'entente et ses
seins je finirai par là mais c'est ça
mon avis qui est crucial là pour cette
ces législatives c'est que de toute
façon quel que soit l'équilibré des
forces politiques
on sera dans l'obligation d'avoir un
quinquennat qui soit ouvert qui compte
quand même dans les sensibilités
différentes pour essayer de trouver une
culture du consensus qu'on est bien loin
d'avoir aujourd'hui on y revient à tout
à l'heure notamment sur peut-être une
jambe gauche un peu faible je viens vous
entendre là dessus jean daniel lévy il
ya cette bannière ensemble qui est
nouvelle il ya le nom du parti
renaissance mis en place alors même
qu'ils nouveau lui aussi c'est un
handicap ou pas finalement la photo des
manuels macron à côté de celle du
candidat ça peut suffire déjà la photo
des paniers le maquereau le côté du
candidat c'est un l'indépassable canton
le problème ne serait ce qu'au cours des
dernières élections législatives et
quand on demande est en fait pourquoi et
vous voter pour un candidat soutenu par
à l'époque la réplique en marche c'était
pour donner majorité au président de la
réplique t'inquiète pas de contenu
politique et pas forcément de
connaissance extrêmement précises de la
part des candidats c'était la logique
des institutions qui ce qu'ils se
privent à la crise et encore ce qui est
en train de se mettre en place
luc mélenchon parce que je pense que ça
va être le cas également de temps pour
aujourd'hui quand même s'il a quelques
personnalités qui sont un peu identifiés
ou d'autres qui peuvent susciter du
débat ce que ce que ce que je trouve
intéressant par rapport à ce que vous
avez indiquée c'est que c'est la
première fois qu on a une organisation
politique qui change autant de noms en
si peu de temps en dehors de faits qui
sont des fakes d'ailleurs parfois quand
on change de nom c'est quand on a un
problème notamment pour ôter le mot
franchement d'affaires et donc qu'on
veut faire en sorte qu'on soit plus
forcément affiliés à des termes qui sont
des termes anciens il y a eu en marche
qui a été constitué avec un objectif qui
était la conquête du pouvoir puis la
république en marche qui a été
constituée pour la gestion du pouvoir et
aujourd'hui il ya une nouvelle formation
avec deux volets qui est le volet
ensemble qui vise à réunir en fait
plusieurs formations politiques et puis
également re naissance renaissance
effectivement des contours sont pas
encore tout à fait clair si on regarde
bien est ce que c'est la réplique en
marche qui se transforme en renaissance
est ce que il ya d'autres formations
politiques il vient de rejoindre mon
enfant tout cas c'est vraiment la start
up nation qui poussait à sa logique
complète c'est-à-dire ont construit des
formations au regard d'objectifs une
fois que l'objectif est atteint eh ben
on va être amené à remettre l'ouvragé
sur le métier et refaire une formation
avec un objectif dont a priori
l'objectif c'est non seulement le gain
des prochaines élections initiative mais
également au fait le prochain
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro alors vous
l'avez évoqué sur le côté professionnel
éléments de langage apprendre apprendre
la prendre la parole à bon escient a
finalement éventuellement valider des
idées de sa majorité même si on en est
un petit peu parfois éloignés bref tout
ça c'est la politique ce qui est
intéressant est bien c'est que là ils
sont aussi venus chercher des éléments
de langage les tout jeunes un candidat
c'est robert mais ça s'appelle un média
training donc en bon en anglais ça veut
dire qu on les entraîne et surtout on
leur passe les éléments de langage les e
dl qu'ils vont devoir répéter ensuite
pour soutenir emmanuel macron on est
encore je crois vous avez raison dans le
scénario de 2017 c'est le simple
objectif de soutenir un homme emmanuel
macron et donc eux sont des lieutenants
sont considérés comme tels
l'armée est là pour soutenir le
président réélu et il doit avoir les
messages qui vont aider justement a
démarré ce second quinquennat et donc
les nerfs et avec christophe malbranque
qui était un ancien de tf1 je ne sais
pas si vous connaissez qui était dans la
formule 1 me semble t'il à tf1 bon bah
il avait changé de métier il s'occupait
d'eux voilà d'entraîner les députés j'ai
tenté de savoir et m'a pas répondu
aujourd'hui c'est parce que peut-être
qu'il est encore là voilà mais en tous
les cas où il se sait vraiment un
séminaire expressément tourner vers ce
média training alors on l'a évoqué je
proposais jonathan dupriez de nous
rejoindre je pense qu'il est juste là
bonsoir
jonathan alors ya pas mal de
personnalités issues
des premiers cercles des coulisses de la
ma chronique qui ressorte en pleine
lumière c'est ça oui absolument et on
avait parlé d'ailleurs et vous en avais
même parlé ici il ya cinq ans ces fameux
308 députés qui venait de la société
civile et dont on dans la macro ni en
tout cas vantait les mérites c'était la
première fois qu'il est entré au palais
bourbon et ce temps on peut peut-être se
demander si à l'orée de ces législatives
il n'est pas en passe d'être révolue on
voit poindre effectivement un retour en
grâce de de pas mal de professionnels de
la politique des collaborateurs
parlementaires des ex-membres même de
cabinets ministériels qui vont être
investis sous cette fameuse bannière
ensemble il y en a une trentaine et
parmi eux on en a rencontré une
notamment shannon se banques à 26 ans
c'est une jeune énarque conseillère
municipale en seine-saint-denis
l'ancienne directrice adjointe de
cabinet bruno le maire je me suis
toujours elle a été parachuté dans la
loire mais elle pense que son expérience
au coeur du pouvoir et bien ça pourra
lui servir regardez c'est aujourd'hui un
atout puisque je connais les rouages des
institutions sont donc j'ai pu
effectivement avoir cette expérience à
la fois de terrain est à la fois une
connaissance des institutions qui je le
crois me seront très utiles dans le
cadre des fonctions à je l'espère de
député voilà déjà d un média traîner
d'autres petites mains de l'ombre aussi
ont obtenu l'investiture c'est le cas
d'adrien comique et le secrétaire
général du groupe en marche au sénat que
nous on côtoie souvent journaliste
politique lui il a hérité d'une
circonscription nord ingagnable celle de
l'ancien patron du raid jean-michel
fauvergue tu lui ne rempile pas c'est en
seine et marne
c'est vrai que j'ai un profil plus
typique vous avez raisons plus
politiques puisque en tant que
secrétaire général du groupe de la
majorité présidentielle au sénat j'étais
plutôt comme vous le disais tout à
l'heure derrière avec une équipe de
conseillers techniques j'ai une
connaissance
particulièrement précises de
l'institution parlementaire au sens
générique du cheminement de la loi je
pense que c'est aussi quelque chose à
faire valoir dans une période où on voit
que les français sont en attente de
nombreuses réformes et puis jonathan
forcément c'est la loi du genre
certaines de ces investitures provoque
quelques remous oui absolument thomas et
certaines se sont faites au détriment de
député sortant qu'il veut briguer un
nouveau mandat qu'ils voulaient repartir
pour un tour exemple dans les
hauts-de-seine un territoire où ça a été
à couteaux tirés un haut niveau dans
marche le sortant de la 7e
circonscription qui s'appelle jacques
marie lotion je sais pas si vous le
connaissez eh bien il a été débranchée
assez sèchement au profit du jeune
pierre cassen 26 ans qui n'était autre
que l'adjoint au chef de cabinet d'
emmanuel macron à l'elysée donc ça c'est
pas un cas isolé l'ancien directeur de
cabinet par exemple de jacques mézard à
la cohésion des territoires lui il a été
parachuté dans l'aveyron ou encore on a
pu relever paul midy qui est le numéro 2
dans marche le bras droit de stanislas
guérini lui il a été investi pour battre
cédric villani qui était un marcheur de
la première heure devenu finalement un
dissident et donc on voit bien
finalement que cette fameuse priorité au
sortant qui avait été éventée par les
huiles de la macro ni et ben alors a pas
fait long feu en tout cas pour
quelques-uns de ses candidats merci
l'attend pour pour toutes ces
explications béatrice giblin on l'a très
rapidement a évoqué mais est ce que
cette cette faiblesse de la jambe gauche
oui vous surprendre cepdendant s'est
investie de menottes est même plus
générale on met dans la coalition la
coalition est ce que bon visiblement
entre les deux tours entre la gauche y
beaucoup le discours enfin le président
s'est dit l attention il faut quand même
un peu que je balise s'était fait sur l
air il fallait faire attention sur la
gauche et puis il ya pourtant territoire
de progrès si je me trompe pas qui fait
partie de la majorité où ils sont passés
on est
censé inspirer par rené par renaissance
peuvent peut-être mais il y avait un
moyen de mettre quelqu'un on avait déjà
une brochette de costume bleu cravate
bleue dans la présentation de
renaissance on aurait pu en mettre un
cinquième de plus un nombre de noms mais
ça c'était quand même assez excusez moi
mais j'ai trouvé quand même ça assez
pitoyable renaissance avec une moyenne
d'âge qui était quand même pas triste si
ferrand c'est quand même pas
gamin de la première heure béroud encore
moins il est quand même septuagénaires
je crois vous désormais
nous avons un fringant président
d'horizon mais qui a la cinquantaine
elle s'y trouvait que pour l'idée de
renaissance franchement annoncé sa
renaissance et ensemble avec cette
brochette l'un comme blouse blanche
aucun cas oui mais ce qu'avoir plus
franchement j'ai été un peu un peu
surprise aux fab le casting il était en
plus il faisait très souvent la tête
vous avez l'air de s'ennuyer beaucoup
sache tenez comme ça c'est sathonay-camp
même pas vraiment envie avec sa germond
vous avez choisi de vous engager auprès
d' edouard philippe s'est passé pinceau
qui on l'a déjà dit ici donc vous
imaginez vous n'avez pas la même lecture
de ce que cette famille mais la photo de
famille était un petit peu à l'ancienne
on est ce que c'est ça un peu vieille
politique
c'était l'issue
c'est un accord institutionnel voilà
donc c'est un accord institutionnel
politique avec des têtes de pont de
partie je note quand même que pour
edouard philippe 50 ans ne me paraît pas
être très vieux il me semble
on disait ces jeunes en politique
politique quand il a pris la parole
franchement c'est pas dynamique c'était
écoutez moi je crois qu'on même qu' il y
a dans cette période où de toute façon
c'est très bien c'est très fébrile
quelles que soient les les côtés où je
vous rejoins c'est qu'effectivement
c'est un accord avec une maison qui est
sur trois piliers mais qui sont des
piliers plutôt à droite avec des valeurs
de droite que on retient quand même que
agir et territoires de progrès au
passage ont été effectivement
certainement inspiré dans dents
naissances ça même pas été dit mais je
crois que c'est que le début de
l'histoire c'est à dire que là on prend
une photo qui est une photo avant même
la campagne on oublie de dire qu'il va
falloir revoir très vite maintenant sur
le terrain de quelle façon cette équipe
institutionnel va se mettre en oeuvre à
se mettre en mouvement en fait sur le
terrain et comment tout simplement les
électeurs vont ressentir les choses
parce que on voit bien vous parliez de à
juste titre de cette de ce rassemblement
aujourd'hui pour l'heure vous parlez de
média training mais c'est aussi un
cadrage des troupes donné l'envi pour
ceux pour qui c'est la première fois
avoir des éléments de cohésion bon
ce qui est notable c'est que la dernière
fois il me semble qu emmanuel macron
n'était pas venu cette fois ci il est
venu donc on voit bien qu'il ya la pâte
présidentielle et ont bouclé la boucle
il ya un choix fait par emmanuel macron
dans le des candidats déjà dans les
candidats circonscrit ce qu'il n'avait
pas fait en 2010 et sur les dernières
circonscriptions ce sont des
circonscriptions sur lesquelles ont si
on comprend bien des musées a un oeil
tout parti jean daniel oui ça on l'a
bien compris jean daniel lévy ces
législatives alors c'est effectivement
vous disiez c'est un peut sembler un peu
paradoxal on voit pas trop la jambe
gauche alors que la campagne de second
tour était vraiment tournée de ce côté
cette saisie cela tu y vas bon plutôt ce
gagner de quel côté de l'échiquier
politique pour le camp de la majorité
présidentielle puisqu'on fait vraiment
un focus sur ce camp là ce soit au delà
par déjà de ceux qui ont été amenés à
voter pour emmanuel macron quels que
soient leur famille politique d'origine
ou le fait qu'il fonctionne plutôt à
gauche ou plutôt à droite dans mon livre
sur votre nez face à des électeurs qui
sont légitimistes on peut rappeler au
cours des dernières élections
législatives
déjà on avait une chute de la
participation moins de 50% de
participation premier tour ou moins de
43 % de participation au deuxième tour
et puis il y avait eu une maximisation
du score de ceux qui avaient porté leurs
voix pour emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron au premier tour de la
présidentielle c'est 24% c'est en gros
un tiers des électeurs qui sont déplacés
au premier tour et qu'on voter pour un
représentant de la formation politique
qui se revendiquait du président de la
réplique donc il ya eu cet élan qui
s'est produit qui me fasse un double
phénomène un phénomène qu'on a toujours
vu peut-être hormis en 1988 c'est à dire
élections législatives qui suivent une
élection présidentielle il ya une sur
mobilisation de l'électorat et lé doublé
d'une dimension à caractère sociologique
ou un électorat qui est plutôt âgées un
électorat qui est plutôt diplôme et un
électorat qui est plutôt urbain et donc
à tendance plus que les autres à se
mobiliser notamment lorsqu'elle est fort
aux flux de participation électorale
donc ça c'était clairement l'enjeu c'est
pas certain et c'est là en fait tout ça
va être intéressant qu'on soit
exactement dans ce même phénomène au
cours de la prochaine élection a listé
des prochaines élections initiatives
notamment parce que déjà le score des
manuels macron au deuxième tour a été
moins important cette fois ci qu'il ne
l'a été en 2007 parce qu'il y avait un
petit élan de dynamisme et dans vie qui
se traduisait après l'élection d'
emmanuel macron auprès du coeur de son
électorat ce qui est un peu moins vrai
aujourd'hui
et puis également parce que on a le
sentiment que la menace qu'une autre
formation politique pourra de nature à
pouvoir entre guillemets prendre sa
revanche est moins perceptible de la
part des électeurs donc ça suscite un
peu moins aujourd'hui dans mouvement de
participation à plusieurs inconnues en
haletant évidemment toujours la
nomination du nouveau gouvernement alors
les deux si vous avez une hypothèse à
propos de la communication à dire profil
bas des manuels mâcon depuis sa
réélection j'aime bien faire des
hypothèses sur le plateau et on peut
dire que depuis le 24 avril on peut dire
que la communication du président réélu
un premier président réélu hors
cohabitation ne va jamais assez le
répéter pourquoi je le répète parce que
ça contraste avec justement cette
communication très profil bas vous avez
raison très minimaliste depuis la fête
encadré au champ de mars y avait pas
vraiment de scènes de liesse habituel
jusqu'à son bref discours d'investiture
finalement on pourrait résumer le
positionnement des manuels maquereau en
trois mots humilité sens de la
responsabilité rassemblement pour les
législatives on a bien compris vous avez
raison il nous l'a fait bien comprendre
aussi que c'était lui qui avait la main
sur toutes les investitures mais pas
vraiment plus que cela et puis pour la
nomination du ou de la première ministre
qui se fait attendre là encore il
applique sa nouvelle doctrine de
communication écouté par exemple ce
qu'il disait à berlin hier aux
journalistes
alors sur la dernière question
oui
mais ce n'est pas ici que je vais le
dire ni maintenant
mais bien entendu et on a le droit
d'avoir de la suite dans les idées mais
de faire les choses en bon ordre donc je
vous rassure donc il a le nom du ou de
la première ministre qui lisent mais
c'est pas là mais c'est pas le moment de
le donner est-ce que emmanuel macron
voilà et dans cette logique plutôt
profil bas parce qu'il craint de ne pas
avoir de majorité à l'assemblée eh bien
non c'est tout le contraire et c'est là
que je pose mon hypothèse sur notre
table comme bouc lui et il se murmure
qu'à l'elysée on a quand même une
justement une tendance qui se consolide
avec les premières projections qui sont
en train d'être élaborée et tout serait
convaincu d'avoir une majorité plus
importante qu'en 2017 mais il ne faut
surtout pas le communiqué avant déjà la
victoire surtout pas communiqué sur une
potentielle victoire peut-être par
superstition mais surtout pour se
laisser l'occasion de communiquer cette
fois après sur cet élan populaire
vraiment spontané qui aurait porté la
nouvelle majorité derrière la réélection
de ce président réélu dans la vème
république et donc il a été donné pour
ordre de surtout continuer à faire
profil bas d'accord les leviers est ce
que c'est une hypothèse crédible une
majorité plus forte qu'il ya cinq ans
pour emmanuel macron à l'assemblée
absolument c'est une force centrale si
on a une abstention qui est relativement
faible on a très peu de chances d'avoir
des triangulaires il y aura probablement
des duels dans toutes quasiment toutes
les circuits des circonscriptions de
france et si vous prenez en fait
l'abstention forte abstention abstention
forte en fait dans ce contexte là on
avait eu plus seule triangulaire si vous
trouvez en 2017 donc ça favorise et déjà
la présence de la réplique en marche au
deuxième tour et quand vous faites des
hypothèses en demandant aux électeurs
est ce que vous préférez dans votre
circonscription
un candidat la réplique en marge d'un
côté ou incroyable france insoumise ou
ses alliés de l'autre ou éventuellement
du rassemblement national voire dlr en
général le plus petit dénominateur
commun reste aujourd'hui la réplique en
marche ou les soutiens de la part du
président nabih nous qui peut très bien
y avoir cet effet paradoxal d'un score
qui au premier tour serait moins
important cette année pour cette force
politique au regard du score qu'elle
avait obtenu en 2007 et dans un mail en
une maximisation du comportement
électoral notamment du fait qu'il puisse
y avoir des côtés de repoussoir qui sont
honnêtes aujourd'hui quand vous êtes à
droite et que vous imaginez en fait jean
luc mélenchon pour pouvant être demain
le premier ministre ça suscite pas
vraiment d'enthousiasmé
bien la litote voilà voilà et donc donc
à ce côté là aussi qui peut être aussi
un côté de remobilisation qu'il n'était
pas encore tout à fait présent et c'est
là où la campagne va être extrêmement
intéressante par ailleurs pour savoir
est-ce que du côté de la nouvelle union
populaire ils vont mettre qu'ils vont
nous continuons campagne sur mélenchon à
matignon ou sur le programme politique
et sera pas forcément exactement la même
incidence sur le comportement général
évidemment je pense qu'il va faire
campagne que sur mélenchon président de
la république premier pas le premier
ministre parce qu'il nous est facile ça
c'est facile parce qu'il ne peut
mobiliser son électorat de banlieue est
essentielle parce que sa géographie
électorale est très intéressante à
regarder c'est pas du tout géographie
électorale nationale c'est une
géographie très particulière l'ancien
banlieue rouge pour faire vite 1 et puis
le sud l'arrière pays du sud de la
france cévennes drôme provençale aveyron
ardèche odza mais il est présent de
façon très forte sur des terres
ouvrières l'a même pas vu il est même
perdu parce que on prend la
circonscription de rufin 30% des voix
pour marine le pen 15% pour mélenchon
dans l'assiette à la présidentielle dans
la circonscription de rufin qui n'est
quand même pas toujours quand même une
certaine ambiguïté à faire un parallèle
comme ça
je suis d'accord mais moi je reste
convaincu que pour mobiliser les gens
c'est pour ça qu'il a dit tout de suite
le soir 3e tour le troisième tour et
c'est moi et c'est moi vous allez
m'élire premier ministre parce que c'est
sur son compte les gens se sont
mobilisés et on a bien vu l'effondrement
de rfi en 2017 quand il a fallu aller
voter aux législatives
bon ben on avait perdu c'était plus
intéressant on allait on n'allait pas y
aller donc ça ça me semble très
important et pour aller dans le sens de
ce que vous dites pour un deuxième tour
qui peut être flamboyant c'est qui a
énormément d'électeurs socialistes qui
ne vont pas avoir envie de voter pour le
candidat et les filles mais ça ne s'est
pas joué cette saison alors justement
sévèrement et ensuite j'en gagne c'est
ça qui va être très intéressant c'est
qu'en bout de course
circonscription par circonscription il
va falloir voir quelles sont les
dissidences potentiel dissidence
évidemment à gauche on en a beaucoup
parlé avec
le parti socialiste essentiellement et
qui est quand même très implanté bien
entendu et qui reste une forme solide
orial ces minorités sociales y sont
minoritaires par rapport au contrat et à
l'accord il est décédé
exactement et donc on peut avoir une
petite dispersion qui a la marge pourra
peut-être changer les choses et puis
surtout quand on aura le nom du ou de la
premier ministre et du gouvernement dans
la foulée
normalement c'est fait aussi pour
redonner un bilan exactement donc
aujourd'hui est ce pour ne pas brouiller
finalement les séquences parce que tant
qu' il faut aller jusqu'au dépôt des
listes quand même en préfecture donc
lundi prochain lundi mardi prochain
--après repartir sur une séquence
nouvelle jean daniel havis la dispersion
à gauche la qu'évoquer béatrice giblin
est ce que vous l'avez étudier est ce
que c'est déjà possible de l'évaluer
l'enfant serait pas été professionnel le
palétuvier et ont
même posé la question plus précise pour
savoir est ce que vous pourriez voter
pour un candidat de la nouvelle mine
populaire issue de la france a soumis du
parti communiste d'europe écologie les
verts il parti socialiste ce qui est
assez intéressant c'est que assez
logiquement en fait quand on est proche
de la france à son mix de là plutôt
tendance à voter pour un candidat issu
la france a soumises plutôt que d'une
personne où il ya un peu moins de
capacité à pouvoir voter pour faire vite
à peu de choses près comme c'est plus
forcément quelqu'un qui est entièrement
de sa formation politique on a
uniquement une personne sur deux qui
déclare oui je serai prêt à voter pour
quelqu'un d'union mais qui
historiquement ne portait pas
complètement monétique est la question à
laquelle on n'arrive pas à répondre et
on va voir dans les prochains jours
c'est est-ce que sur les affiches est ce
que dans le cas de la campagne ou est ce
que dans le cadre de l'identification de
la part des électeurs ils connaîtront
l'histoire ou le patrimoine entre
guillemets génétique de la personne qui
sera candidate est ce qu'ils seront que
le candidat qui sera présenté comme le
candidat de la gauche pour faire vite ce
sera un combat d'une nouvelle gauche ou
est ce que ce sera un combat libre de la
mouche issue vers le parti est sûre on
verra aussi dans un coin de la fisu
partie
sera une incidence en tout cas
aujourd'hui on voit une petite gêne
quand même de la part des électeurs
socialistes à l'égard des électeurs qui
sont issus la france a soumise mais
c'est pas certain que ce soit
complètement identifiable même alors la
formation du la nomination du nouveau
gouvernement ça va forcément donner un
coup d'accélérateur à 7 à cette campagne
ce qui est sûr c'est que ça soulagera
aussi les responsables de la majorité
qui savent plus trop quoi dire en
attendant on écoute clément bonne et
pour commencer christophe castaner
président a confirmé que son mandat se
termine en 13 ce sera dans la foulée
donc à partir de samedi prochain
j'imagine mais ils jouent elles
totalement exclue durant avec jusqu'à
quand ça faisait je veux qu'ils se
battent il me consulte pas pour
constituer le gouvernement sinon je
rentrais nous annoncer que je suis
premier ministre et ça n'est pas le cas
je pense que dans la semaine avec un
mandat dont nous savions tous qu'il se
terminait le 13 mai le quinquennat
précédent et donc il organise cela il
consulte il échange il poursuit son
travail et ne vous inquiétez pas la
france aura un gouvernement je n'ai
aucun doute sur le sujet c'était je
crois que prend la république a répondu
à cette question pouvait-il avoué qu'il
n'hésitait qu'il ne trouvait pas le bon
profil
il semble que oui mais je vais vous dire
il n'appartient qu'à lui de le savoir de
décider et de le faire savoir via un
mandat qui va jusqu'au 13 mai et donc
soyez patiente mais je pense que dans
les quelques jours qui viennent vous
aurez des informations complémentaires
en beauté ce matin sur lci avec saint
germain vous pariez pour un profil
plutôt
technique là jean castex ou plutôt
politique
c'est une question presque piège parce
que
je crois qu'il faut en tout cas la
question de savoir si c'est une femme ou
pas je mets de côté parce que pour moi
c'est ça devient accessoire si on
regarde le profil d'abord de compétences
je pense qu'il faut une compétence pour
porter les sujets de faut être une
légitime défaut de compétence il faut
une vraie légitimité sur les sujets de
de climat de transition écologique donc
il va falloir un marqueur fort là dessus
il faut quand même un marqueur fort
également pour une
retraite parce que avec ce qui s'annonce
il va quand même falloir également
quelqu'un qui qui connaît bien et là on
retrouve la question de la compétence
et puis quand même quelqu'un de
politique parce que avec avant tout
aussi parce que avec la difficulté que
l'on va avoir notamment peut-être dans
les mois qui viennent où il faut essayer
de rassembler pour le coup ce qui était
parent donc ça va être très compliqué
vous êtes obligés d'avoir quelqu'un qui
a en tout cas une expérience politique
suffisante pour gérer matignon
gérer les crises qui s'annonce est
portée des réformes qui sont essentiels
ségolène royal
ben voilà tout le monde rigole donc
savez vous vous annoncez vous avancer
des idées audacieuses à la question que
mais quand même on est persuadé comme
tant d'autres une femme se serait même
une femme peut-il ne pas nommer une
femme après avoir laissé fuiter que
c'était quand même aujourd'hui peu de
priorité oui mais bien toujours dit
peut-être oui peut ne pas nommer une
femme oui je pense que les français sont
très conscients des enjeux il l'avait
aussi la première voilà la première de
la situation il se fera pas piéger à
mettre une femme s'il estime qu'elle n'a
pas toutes les qualités parce que non
seulement est fabriqué les du sens
politique mais faudra aussi qu'elle est
une certain charisme et autorités pour
pouvoir entraîner tout ça et ça va pas
être si simple quand même que ça donc
c'est quand même une perle rare un ou
tous les cas la dimension à
planification écologique il ne peut pas
les quarts à placer lui
qui vient de l'écologie pas sûr parce
que quand jade ou fait moins de 5% des
voix ça veut bien dire mais la
planification écologique il faut quand
même et leur polo va dire mélenchon
encore faut-il qu'il ou elle accepte
quand même il ya eu un certain quand on
vous propose pas matignon et je sais pas
alors il ya les refus ils sont il ya la
fatigue non mais nous y en a une valérie
rabault n'est pas sûr que ça lui était
jamais vraiment proposer on laisse
courir le bruit que mais enfin on n'en
sait rien quentin véronique b d'agde il
a dit vous êtes bien gentil mais moi je
ne vais pas me mettre à prendre ce poste
là elle a un poste qu'il intéresse
énormément qui est important je crois
qu'elle chez natixis
voilà avec un paul un poste important
elle se dit bon je serais pas allé
m'embarquer dans sexy à son âge elle n'a
pas décidé de faire de politique c'est
pas pour hubble devenir premier ministre
comme ça sent vraiment une réelle
expérience politique ça aurait été même
une erreur là on aurait dit on mais
revient à la musique et la société s'ils
sont expulsés elle était directrice de
carbine de cabinet de manuel valls a mis
d'accord mais ça fait déjà un moment et
c'est pas une experte c'est pas une
expérience de terrain de contact d'élus
moi je pense qu'en ce moment c'est un
peu au dessus aussi c'est ça mais bon
comme il manque pas d'audace
tactique pas forcément sur le long terme
et le la nomination du pr ministre
vraiment tenté la coloration de cette
campagne électorale
on le rappelle l'arrivée en fait
d'edouard philippe à matignon a changé
fondamentalement davantage la couleur de
la chambre à l'assemblée nationale il y
avait en gros nous on a évalué à 100
députés et qui normalement devait aller
du côté des républicains qui au final
ont basculé à la république en marche
parce que il voir philippe est arrivé
enfin il a dit je suis droite et parce
qu'on est des électeurs qui globalement
été droite pour tout un tas de raisons
ne pouvaient pas voter pour françois
fillon à la présidentielle sont dit on
va voter pour le candidat ait l'air dans
notre circonscription soldats on n'a pas
compris en fait on l'a gagné et donc et
qui ont changé complètement leur fusil
d'épaulé faire et ont voté pour le
candidat la réplique en marche sans
avoir le sentiment globalement des
leçons ni trahir en adoptant ce
comportement électoral donc il y aura
vraiment oui un vrai message extrêmement
fort qui sera donnée par le ou la
premier ministre et puis également par
la composition du gouvernement et puis
on peut toujours rêver on va peut-être
enfin parler du fond parce que là ça
fait 15 jours qu'on est plutôt sur la
cuisine électorale et que ça germond
peut-être enfin comparer un peu les
programmes et s'intéresser au contenu et
c'est le plus important c'est le plus
important en tout cas ce sont aussi des
points sur lesquels au contact sur le
terrain
c'est ce qui intéresse les électeurs
tout simplement aussi c'est d'arriver
alors après est-ce que ça motive
complètement le vote je vois votre
scepticisme sur le sujet mais en tout
cas c'est ce qui fait les échanges sur
le terrain c'est à dire que vraiment
quelle que soit pour comprendre la
lisibilité
essayer de retracer finalement le fils
depuis l'élection la réélection du
président le virage très très marqué qui
a été fait aussi entre les deux tours et
puis maintenant redonner cette dynamique
se sera teintée effectivement avec le
gouvernement avec le premier ministre le
gouvernement et là on va aller dans les
propositions et dans l'ancrage terrain
c'est à dire qu'après vous allez
retrouver les questionnements
circonscription par circonscription en
dix ans et vous si vous êtes élu député
qu'est ce que vous faites bien sur tel
sujet qui doit venir qu'est ce que vous
faites c'est comme ça en fait qu'à
partir du tronc commun les
personnalités politiques vont pouvoir
s'implanter et d'où la difficulté de
l'ancrage et avec un thème majeur mais
ce sera le cas notre second débat qu'est
le thème économie que le pouvoir d'achat
la hausse de l'inflation qui est quand
même centrale aujourd'hui dans les
préoccupations des français voudrait
qu'on consacre quelques minutes sur une
autre information du jour alors là
pardon mais on revient vraiment dans la
cuisine électorale c'est le journalisme
militant tabou apps qui est soutenu par
la france insoumise qui retire sa
candidature à vénissieux vous le savez
là étaient ils avaient été condamnés à
l'automne dernier pour injure publique
après avoir traité une syndicaliste
policière d'arabe de service jean luc
mélenchon a réagi en dénonçant
c'était sur twitter je cite une meute
qui cette anarchie acharné pardon contre
tabou avec béatrice giblin est ce que
c'est un premier accroc au sein de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale comme cette société surtout un
mauvais choix c'était un mauvais choix
parce que c'était quelqu'un qui était
posée une vraiment problème avec des
déclarations qu'ils étaient des
déclarations vraiment
parfois presque communautariste enfin
mettant en question la laïcité au delà
de la bru haussière tct et d'avoir
traité cette position syndicale d'un rap
de service bon c'est un journaliste qui
a pris un peu la grosse tête et qui a
pensé qu'ils pouvaient tous fermés l'isi
surveillance yeux ce serait l'erreur
on met des outils bien si vous voulez
bien
défini comme tel mais surtout à
vénissieux où on avait un terrain
très marqué à gauche avec une mère qui
fait très bien son travail
on ne l'a pas concertés mais c'est comme
ça que fonctionne et les filles c'est le
patron qui a décidé qu'ils ont mais t'es
où bon combat seulement les
finitions mais il se trouve on évoquait
tout à l'heure
la mauvaise
c'est le cas aussi au ps et chez les
verts de la même manière mais comme l'a
si vous voulez il a quand même
l'essentiel des circonscriptions c'est
quand même lui qui a marqué très très
fortement mais sa déclaration je
regrette de ne pas l'avoir assez soutenu
et assez défendu me semble extrêmement
maladroite ces racines là dans cette
circonscription la deux vénissieux
citions la maire communiste lévis
immédiatement après l annonce du retrait
de taboye c'est à dire bon ben voila je
me présentais les filles a tout de suite
refusé et va présenter un candidat
pourquoi parce qu'elle est gagnable
fortement gagna pour
manu paix sous la peau du cou a priori
facile des circonscriptions pour
lesquels on l'a peu de doute c'est ça
qui peut être intéressant en plus je
crois et je passe sur les i à rappeler
c'est que le premier coup de canif a été
porté par fabien roussel
candidat communiste qui hier s'il me
trompe pas sur france 2 mais a indiqué
que ça lui posait un problème n'est
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs cela il ya une
autre question qui se pose c'est quel
rapport à la réplique on peut avoir et
lé rapport à la laïcité on sait que ce
sont des enjeux qui voulaient les
factures
quand on revoit la campagne de fabien ou
celle de jean luc mélenchon la mairie
lecture et là sur sap a été et ça a été
plus sur un propos qui est à propos à
caractère politique et un peu en fait de
condamnation mais qui étaient en lien
justement avec la question politique
était posée par famille roussel et qui
va faire que à un moment ou un autre ces
sujets là vont être amenés à rejaillir
parce qu'en fait aboaf n'est pas très
connue la part du grand public les
électeurs ne connaissent pas forcément
neutre est très bien identifié les
grands militants le savent qui sait en
tout cas que derrière cela va se pose
est évidemment d'autres questions qui
vont qui vont arriver récemment on a vu
par exemple que le maire de grenoble em
ecologie les verts a parlé en fait des
espaces ouverts dans les piscines à
l'égard des femmes qui voulaient porter
absolument donc il ya forcément des
lignes de fracture aujourd'hui qui sont
un tout petit peut passer sous silence
et qui vont forcément réémerger et qui
vont traverser la gauche de manière
manifeste au cours des semaines ou des
mois et ça passera notamment par des
candidatures dissidentes alors ça
seulement mais non
et puis par des moments en fait il y
aura soit démobilisés social se voit des
soutiens apportés à l'égard des
différents candidats c'était le cas
lorsqu'il ya eu des mobilisations qui
sont déroulés signe ne trompe pas il ya
un an et demi avec le ccf qui était dans
avec des interrogations concernant le
rapport qu'il peut y avoir à l'islam le
rapport qui pourrait avoir à l'égard du
voile etc qui sont des sujets
extrêmement brûlant qui traverse
l'ensemble de rester française qui ont
été pas forcément complètement soldes et
je pense dans le cas des accords qui ont
été signés entre les différentes
formations politiques qui se trouvait
dans la nuque place mais qui à mon avis
à un moment ou à un autre vous ré
émerger de manière très très manifeste
merci beaucoup merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat